earlier i spoke to the deputy prime
minister dominic rabb i started by
asking him about jess phillips comments
in the comments
let me put this to you that jess
phillips said yesterday in the house
was the prime minister present at the
event in his flat
on the 13th of november i assume he
doesn't need other people to tell him
whether he was there or not
um was he at the flat event listed in
the report on the 13th of november do
you need a place to tell him that well
he doesn't need the police telling that
but if he does start answering specific
questions that have been referred to the
police he will be accused in fact fairly
and rightly of prejudicing or preempting
or interfering in that investigation
which is why just fix penalty notices
well there's still the look you can't
have it both ways okay you can't say on
the one hand the uh the sanctions are
not very high and on the other hand it's
a very serious issue we take it very
seriously those incidents have gone
you need to be allowed the time to
investigate in which case
it's very serious as you said in your
own words so he should step down if he's
found guilty of any of those offenses
and let's wait and see what the just
said you can't have it both ways as well
i'm not i'm having it one way which is
allow the police to conduct their
investigation and see when they've
ascertained the facts quite what uh they
conclude and of course there'll be full
transparency around that and look i get
your frustration the public's
frustration no one is in mine i'm asking
these questions on behalf of them
and i think they're public but i think
we want this done and dusted as soon as
possible okay well this is what the
former prime minister said
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
i don't think actually that's quite
right in terms of what the sugray report
did it said that they hadn't lived up to
the standards that would have been
expected but in relation to specific
breaches
of leadership actually as well yes but
which is not quite what um uh teresa
said but in relation to the 12 specific
instances where there are alleged
breaches those have gone to the police
and it's quite right to wait for them to
conduct that investigation did you
believe in the lockdown that you and
your colleagues championed
yes i did and i think and i thought it
was
yeah absolutely why are the police
investigating 12 separate incidents
that took part in downing street because
if there's any precisely because there's
a lot there so let me answer the
question precisely because it's
important precisely because i get the
argument about double standards where
there have been uh allegations claims
assertions that rules have been broken
it is absolutely right that first of all
it was referred to grey and sue grey is
now if there's any potential breach of
the law referred it to the police and
they should look at it and uh we've been
very clear there'll be transparency and
accountability that will follow that the
police have said that they will
interview people that were at these
events and we know that the prime
minister was at at least three you were
trying to jump ahead of the
investigation uh i would like to but
that's not true
i'm going to as i said throughout we
know he was at least three events don't
we and the police have said that they
will investigate anybody or speak to
anybody that was at those events the
sitting prime minister and his wife
being interviewed by the police but that
hasn't happened yet uh uh um kate nearly
called you sir
i know you did um but look we're both
formidable
because it's true um but the police will
conduct that investigation i'm not going
to start commenting about uh interviews
that haven't taken but the police have
already commented they've already said
that they're going to investigate people
that were at the parties and we know
that the prime minister was at least
three ergo they're going to interview
the prime minister i think there's a lot
hanging on your ergo but the the reality
is the police will conduct that
investigation